I just think there's shitty people and then there's not shitty people.
I really do not think it's all men.
I'm not on that team. I'm one of the more gender equal kind of,
kind of feminist women. Like,
I don't hate men. I have a boyfriend,
I live with a man. I have a son.
I think because I'm a mother and I have a son,
I'm not gonna paint men with this broad brush
and kind of throw them all away,
because I have a son, and I know he has a beautiful little heart,
and I've watched it, so I helped grow it.
I think the way that men have been raised in past generations to, like,
try to, like,
make them stay cavemen, like,
we weren't letting them become full humans
with feelings and thoughts and emotions,
and there was this pressure on them to be this provider and blah, blah,
blah. And I think some men, like,
super lean into that because it's easier,
it's safer than having to talk about your feelings
and feel your feelings and shit.
I have encountered many kind men in my life.
I have had many friends that I respect.
And I just think since most men,
up until this point,
we're not raised to feel their feelings or think about other people,
empathy was just beyond them.
It seems like it's a lot of men.
And with the way violence towards women has handled
and how many men Like just whether they're one of the good ones,
but they just sit there and stay quiet.
I think things like that can make a lot of resentment towards men.
But. No,
it's not all men, but. Yeah,
but I would never be like not all men, cause